بدانا نشاهد اذا ونسمع بعض تداعيات هذه
العمليه في بيروت يوم امس يعني من مسيرات
ودعوات للانتقام وتوعد بالرد ايضا من قبل
المقاومه ومن قبل ايضا حزب
الله نعم اولا ليست هناك حاجه ان تعلن
اسرائيل مسؤوليتها عن اغتيال الشيخ صالح
العاروري فكل من عينيه في راسه يعرف من
يقف ومن نفذ هذه العمليه سواء اعلنت اس
مسؤوليتها ام لم تعلن منذ بدايه الحرب وفي
ايامها الاولى وضمن اجراءاتها الانتقاميه
كانت قد دهمت منزله في قريه عروره مسقط
راسه الشمالي مدينه رام الله واستولت عليه
وحولته الى محطه ل الشباك وبدات باجراء
عمليات تنكيل وتحقيق مع المواطنين هناك ثم
قامت بهدمه وهو بيت خالن من اهله منذ ان
رحلت العاروري الى الخارج
منذ عام
2010 لذلك كان واضحا بمن هي الجهه التي
تقف خلف ذلك وكانت الليله الماضيه قد شهدت
في اسرائيل بالاضافه الى الغاء اجتماع
الطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر ومنع كافه
الوزراء والنواب في حزب اللكود من الادلاء
بتصريحات وان تمكن بعضهم من التهليل
والتكبير على اغتيال العاروري الا انه كان
واضحا من ابقاء الاجتماع هو لمجلس الحرب
فقط ومن ثم الاعلان صباح اليوم عن انه تم
رفع درجه التاهب الى درجتها القصوى على
الحدود مع لبنان وتعزيز منظومه القبه
الحديديه بان من ي ان اسرائيل استهدف كان
العاروري بالنسبه لها المستهدف الاول من
بين كافه قاده حركه حماس وصباح هذا اليوم
كدلى مسؤولون اسرائيليون ومحللون بان ان
العاروري كان بنظر اسرائيل واحد من ثلاثه
الذين علموا بامر عمليه طوفان الاقصى وان
تاريخه يعود الى انه من الاباء المؤسسين
لكتائب القسام بالضفه الغربيه منذ بدايه
تسعينيات القرن الماضي قضى في السجن نحو
18 عاما
واى معظمها كانت بالاعتقال الاداري ودون
تهمه او ادانه لانها لم تتمكن ان تاخذ منه
اي اعتراف فات هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه كما قلت كان هناك
رد تغريده ل سموتريتش من الصهيونيه
الدينيه لكنه كما يبدو عاد ومسحها بعد ان
امر بعدم الادلاء باي تصريحات ويقول فيها
ليهلك اعداؤك يا اسرائيل في اشاره الى
اغتيال العاروري كما ان كان هناك تهجم
واضح على الموقف الامريكي الذي انتق قد
الدعوات المتواصله في اسرائيل لتهجير
الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه
وامور اخرى كثيره وتحليلات على صعيد وسائل
الاعلام
الاسرائيليه متواصله وهناك من يشير الى ان
اغتيال الشيخ العاروري قد يكون بدايه
لسلسله اغتيالات قد تنفذها اسرائيل في
قادم الايام ضد قاده اخرين من حركه حماس
خاصه وانها تواصل حربها في داخل قطاع غزه
هذه الحرب التي قال يواف جلاند خلال تفقد
قواته في شارع صلاح الدين في غزه بانها لن
تتوقف وستتواصل حتى تحقق اهدافها لانها
دون تحقيق اهدافها لن يكون بامكان اسرائيل
العيش في الشرق الاوسط هذا على الصعيد
الاسرائيلي على الصعيد الفلسطيني قيمه
الشيخ العاروري كانت لافته وواضحه من ان
جميع القوى وال فصائله بما فيها حركه فتح
والحكومه الفلسطينيه نعت الشيخ العاروري
وان هناك اضراب عام وشامل في كافه ارجاء
الضفه الغربيه حدادا على الشيخ العاروري
كما ان كافه البلدات والمدن ومعظمها قد
شهد مسيرات امتدت الى ما بعد منتصف الليل
الماضيه يندد ويطالب بالانتقام للعار
واخوانه وهذا مؤشر على القيمه التي كان
يحظى بها كقائد ليس لحركه او في حركه حماس
وانما كقائد وطني واسلامي في الضف في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه خاصه وانه تميز بانه
كان من دعاه الوحده وانهاء الانقسام وعوده
اللحمه الى المجتمع والمنظومه السياسيه
الفلسطينيه على كل حال الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بعد اغتيال العاروري واضح بانه
اح حدث صدمه هائله وكبيره الكل الان ينتظر
ما سيكون عليه الحال بعد اغتياله من تصعيد
او من رد ان صح التعبير سواء من لبنان او
من داخل قطاع غزه